hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show got a lot coming up for you
this hour we're going to go through joe
biden's inaugural address as the 46th
president
of the united states technically he's
actually the 45th president because
grover cleveland was president twice but
sure he's the 46th president
of the united states next hour we'll be
going through president trump's farewell
and what we can expect from a
biden administration nothing
particularly wonderful so
the events went off without a hitch
today sort of an
odd feeling because obviously we were
watching an inauguration take place in
the middle of a pandemic
there's a military lockdown in
washington dc about 15 000 troops
in washington dc this hour by the way is
sponsored by expressvpn your data is
your business protected at
expressvpn.com
so washington dc was largely locked down
the the people who were at the event
were not only all mass which is usual
but also they were all sitting
quite far apart from one another with
that said
the spectacle of it was still rather
stunning considering that you saw
these 400 000 flags in honor of the 400
000 people who have died of covet in the
united states
the the actual pageant and pomp of the
thing were still
pretty well done and that's what you
would expect now i mean to be frank with
you i'm not a big fan of pageant and
pomp
in any circumstances with regard to the
presidency of the united states simply
because
to me the president ought to be treated
like a plumber i think we should swear
him in the back of a taxi cab and then
he should just start plumbing as soon as
he gets to the white house
all of this he's the leader of the
country and the conscience of the nation
kind of stuff and i prefer my family
to be my conscience but in any case it
is what it is
so the activities of the day led off
with joe biden being sworn in
here was joe biden being sworn in as
president now you got it
you got to give it to him uh the fact is
that this guy's been pretty persistent
he's been running for president since he
was 30 years old he's now 172 years old
so that it just shows you that ambition
limitless ambition and enough time can
make nearly anybody president here was a
joe biden being sworn in
today please raise your right hand
and repeat after me i joseph
robinette biden jr do solemnly swear hi
joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
that i will faithfully execute that i
will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states office of president of the united
states
and will to the best of my ability the
world to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend preserve
protect
and defend the constitution of the
united states constitution of the united
states
so help you god so help me god
congratulations mr president
sworn in by chief justice robert so
difficult to tell which one of the two
is the bigger democrat on on podium
at the time then kamala harris actually
was sworn in before joe biden so
technically because she was sworn in
before
joe biden that means that she was
actually donald trump's
vice president for like a brief moment
in director so you can
you could say trivia question now
there's nine minutes there where kamala
harris was the first female
vice president under donald trump which
is kind of weird but in any case
she was sworn in the best part of this
was actually sonia sotomayor who swore
her in
botching her name while swearing her in
now i was i was informed reliably by all
of our media sources that if you botch
kamala harris's name if you put the
emphasis on the wrong syllable this
means that you are a racist
so if you call her kamala as opposed to
kamala this means you're a racist
remember tucker carlson got hit with
that charge here with sonia sotomayor
watching it during her actual
swearing-in
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i kamala davie harris do solemnly swear
that i will support and defend the
constitution of the united states that i
will support
and defend the constitution of canada
against
all enemies born and dominated against
all enemies
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the sin
allegiance okay so we can uh we can
dispense with this
so you know it's always a nice american
moment when people swear field
of the constitution it's been quite a
while since literally anybody who's
sworn field sees the constitution
in a public office has been abided by
the constitution but it's a nice idea
anyway
so then joe biden gets up and he gives
his inaugural address and we all knew
what the theme of the address was going
to be it was going to be unity
now it's pablo i mean most presidents
get up there and talk about american
unity
but this one for the press particularly
had special resonance because of course
he was replacing donald trump who they
see as the most polarizing and divisive
president
in american history now it happens to be
true that donald trump was not captain
unity he's not somebody who tend to
bring somebody together
but we've heard empty promises of unity
before namely
joe biden's president when he was vice
president was barack obama who spent
years proclaiming that there are no
states no red states no blue sites
just the united states it was barack
obama who pledged that we were going to
unify as americans
we're going to see beyond race there's a
magical moment
when he was inaugurated he had like 75
approval rating
most americans were like wow what a
great moment and then
by unity and hope and changiness barack
obama proceeded to mean
identity politics divvying up people by
race forming coalitions of the ascendant
to silence half of america calling the
rest of america a bunch of bitter
clingers
and racists foisting on americans a
bunch of
giant government policy they really
didn't like very much
and using the power of the pen and the
phone to override all
limitations on the executive branch
that's what he meant by unity
so before i start celebrating the
newfound unity in washington dc i have
to ask what the unity means because it's
had several definitions over the years
unity could mean that we are all unified
in spending your taxpayer money
which they are it could mean that they
actually
wish for us to share some certain common
values like the first amendment
freedom of association freedom of the
press the ability to descend freedom of
religion we leave each other alone
that'd be a nice kind of unity
right that there is a certain diversity
within unity we acknowledge each other's
rights and then we leave each other
alone
or they could mean by unity shut the
hell up and do what we want you to do
because that is unifying and it turns
out that unity exists in a wide variety
of areas of life it can exist in
democracies it can exist in
dictatorships it can
exist in everything in between so what
exactly does joe biden mean
by unity has left has we still have to
find out
how he's going to define all that in any
case
biden gets up and uh the media have been
spending all day
just on a zoom call with jeffrey toobin
i mean they they cannot get over it i
mean
they are just ecstatic about everything
that has happened this is the moment
in which they get relief sweet relief
they're high-fiving each other in the
streets
america is saved people are tweeting out
in the media stuff like
we overthrew the dictator it's like well
no actually if you just vote out the guy
who's the president and a new guy
replaces him
that is definitionally not overthrowing
a dictator but in any case everybody was
super excited and this this was the
greatest
the greatest inauguration address you've
ever heard according chris wallace
over at fox news he said this was the
single greatest inauguration speech
he has ever heard that it may be the
greatest inauguration speech since jfk
in 1961.
now there are things that to like about
the speech we'll get to in a second
but at the end of this is anyone gonna
remember a single line of the speech
maybe one certainly not two and joe
biden won't remember either
joe biden gave an inaugural address it
was basically
written in the stars that as soon as he
spoke the media were going to declare it
the greatest address they'd ever heard
suddenly joe biden
who has never spoken well is a master of
just incredible oratory the theme of his
speech of course was unity which is nice
i mean i think we would all like a
little bit of unity right now like get
together be nice to each other
some basic manners would be good the
question as i keep saying over and over
is
what does he mean by unity by unity does
he mean shut up and do what i say
so here was joe biden suggesting once
again
unity unity and unity he says america is
facing challenges and that we need unity
to overcome
those challenges to overcome these
challenges
to restore the soul and secure the
future of america
requires so much more than words
requires the most elusive of all things
in a democracy
unity unity
in another january on new year's day in
abraham lincoln signed the emancipation
proclamation
when he put pen to paper the president
said and i quote
if my name ever goes down into history
it'll be for this act and my whole
soul is in it
my whole soul is in it today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause it's a very nice idea
right i mean that we should all unify
and we should treat each other decently
there's only one problem what he means
by unity is still up for debate
and as he would be short to explain it
turns out
that a lot of you a lot of you out there
in the audience
you're not prepared for joe biden's kind
of unity you might be on the other side
of that kind of unity you might be one
of those dark forces out there that's
wrecking our unity here is joe biden on
that theme
i know speaking of unity can sound to
some like a foolish fantasy these days
i know the forces that divide us are
deep and they are real
but i also know they are not new
our history has been a constant struggle
between the american ideal that we all
are created equal
and the harsh ugly reality that racism
nativism fear demonization
have long torn us apart okay so here is
where things start to go off the rails
for me
so the first couple sentences there
where he says the unity sounds like a
foolish fantasy
and that the forces that divide us are
deep and they are real well at this
point you might want to talk about you
know some different visions of america
the visions of america that suggest that
the government needs to be involved in
every aspect of your life versus the
vision of america that says that
government does not need to be involved
in every aspect of your life that's a
pretty deep division
the division that says that freedom of
religion is primary and freedom of
association is primary
and the vision that says the government
needs to compel particular association
because there are too many mean people
out there right
these are real divides and what he could
say is and i want to hear
all those opinions and then together we
can make the best policy instead what he
suggests
is that what's really dividing us is
that some people in america
are just bad now there are people in
america who are racist there are some
people in america who are nativist or
fearful
or or are interested in demonizing the
other side
okay that is certainly true but the real
things that are that are
ripping the nation in half is not about
half the nation being bad it's about
one half of the nation having a vision
for the country and the other half of
the nation not really having the same
vision for the country
he betrays no evidence in this speech
that he even understands the other side
let alone wants to unify
with them and this was the problem with
with president obama
obama used to say this kind of stuff all
the time right i want to get together oh
you and i we should have a conversation
and then if you don't agree with me at
the end it's because i didn't explain
myself particularly well
or because you're a bigot those are the
only two options
how about showing some belief that
there's a point of view different than
your own
that might actually be right how about a
little epistemic humility
now i've lived long enough to see that a
client in american politics it did not
start
under trump it started under barack
obama
it got worse under trump and i have no
faith or at least very little faith that
it's going to get significantly better
under joe biden if he proceeds to speak
words of unity
and then push forward with an agenda
of disunity an agenda of polarization
an agenda of radicalism and an agenda of
of using the reigns of power
in order to in order to push for
policies
that crack down on the rights of
individual americans